MIMI KRAVETZ: Hi everyone.
Welcome to the Talks
at Google event
on "Supersurvivors:
The Surprising Link
Between Suffering and Success."
In a moment, I'll introduce
you to the authors, Lee Daniel
Kravetz and David B.
Feldman, but first I
wanted to steal the
floor because I'm not
only the Googler who's
organizing this event,
but I'm also Lee's wife, and
I've been part of this book
since the very beginning.
So five years ago, Lee
and I went for a walk,
and he had just
survived his own trauma,
and we were talking
about how he really
wanted to do something
meaningful in the world
coming out of that.
And we were also talking about
how every time he told people
about his experience, we heard
the most incredible stories
back.
And we wondered
what factors went
into how somebody
experiences a trauma
and how they come out of it.
And that was really the germ of
an idea that led to this book.
And so, it's so awesome
to be here today
introducing Lee and Dave to
talk about their published
book that's out
there in the world.
Lee Daniel Kravetz
has a master's degree
in Counseling Psychology
and is a graduate
of the University of Missouri
School of Journalism.
He's held positions at the
VA Palo Alto Health Care
System, the National Center
for PTSD, Stanford University
Hospital, and now works at a
private practice in Palo Alto.
He's written for
print and television,
including the New York
Times, Psychology Today,
Huffington Post, as well as
Frontline, NOVA, and Sesame
Street, which our three-year-old
is thrilled about.
He lives in the San
Francisco Bay Area with me
and our two very cute kids.
David B. Feldman
is considered to be
among the top experts on hope
in the field of psychology.
He's an Associate Professor
of Counseling Psychology
at Santa Clara University.
He holds a PhD in Clinical
Psychology from the University
of Kansas and completed
a postdoctoral fellowship
in the VA Palo Alto
Health Care System ,
a medical center associated
with Stanford University.
Dr. Feldman is the author
of two previous books
and has written for Psychology
Today and the Huffington Post
and published numerous
research articles.
He lives in the San
Francisco Bay Area
with his partner
who's also here today.
DAVID FELDMAN: And adorable cat.
MIMI KRAVETZ: And they
will be in conversation
with Dan Ariely.
Dan is the James B. Duke
Professor of Psychology
and Behavioral Economics
at Duke University
and is the author of
New York Times Best
Sellers, "Predictably
Irrational,"
"The Upside of Rationality,"
and "The Honest Truth About
Dishonesty."
And Dan also works with
us here at Google now.
In the SP&E team in
the Irrational Labs.
It's a great honor to introduce
all three of these gentlemen
and I'll turn it over to them.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID FELDMAN: Thank you.
Can you hear me OK?
Is this OK or do I need to
speak more into the mike?
I've got my little lapel thing.
I think what we'll
do is I'll talk
for a few minutes about the
journey that led us to write
this book and a little bit
about our process writing it.
Lee will talk a little bit.
We'll read from the
book for a few minutes,
and then we will take our
positions here on these chairs
and have a little conversation.
And Dan is prepared to
ask us some questions.
So first of all, it's great
to see so many people here.
I'm told the people tend to
come two or three minutes late
to these events, and people
were here early, which is great.
Sorry we were a little
late getting started.
I didn't know it, walking into
my Foundations of Personality
and Psychotherapy class
in the Fall of 2010.
But I was about to embark on a
fun and meaningful and exciting
journey that would bring me and
Lee up until this very point.
As Mimi told you
a second ago, I'm
a Professor at Santa
Clara University,
just down the street from here.
And I teach one of the most
boring classes on earth,
Foundations of Personality
and Psychotherapy.
This is the class that I think
a lot of students dread taking
because we go through theory.
It's just a theory
course, and they
have to take tests
and write papers.
And these people want
to be counselors.
So that's not their thing.
So we talk about Freud, and we
talk about cognitive theory,
and we talk about humanistic
and person-centered approaches
to how the mind works.
And I try to keep it a little
lively and a little interesting
so less people will fall asleep.
I didn't know it
walking in that day,
but it would be one of the most
meaningful groups of students
that I would ever teach.
It was a fantastic
group of students.
I can see the classroom now.
And seated in the middle,
in the very middle--
it was a stepped classroom,
and on the second step,
in the very center-- was
a guy named Lee Kravetz.
And I didn't know
his name at the time
because I'm the jerk who doesn't
learn students names very
easily.
I still don't.
What is your name?
But I would learn it about
three or four weeks later,
when I would give a
lecture on Existentialism.
So for those of you who aren't
familiar with Existentialism,
it is a psychological
perspective, these days,
imported from German philosophy.
People like Nietzsche.
And it has a lot of
German words in it
that bore the heck
out of people.
So I try to keep students awake
by asking them pesky questions,
and asking them to
do pesky things that
are designed to make them think.
For instance I ask
them to calculate
how many years they
have left to live.
And then I ask
them how much time
they've wasted up
until this point.
And generally I get-- sort
of like you did right there--
blank stares in
response to this.
Sometimes people come up and
say it was a meaningful question
to ask, and it changed
the way that they thought.
But what I noticed is that
Lee started to tear up.
And it's rare in a master's
class in Counseling Psychology
that someone starts crying
in the middle of a lecture.
Perhaps it was
because it was boring.
I later found out though that
he came across that tear very
honestly.
As Mimi mentioned, he had
suffered his own trauma.
At the age of 29, Lee suffered
an ordeal with cancer, one
that he would
eventually win, but that
made him question whether
he was going to die.
Something that somebody at the
age of 29 shouldn't have to do.
And as a result, he
dramatically changed his life.
He went from someone who was
working in New York as a book
publicist-- very
convenient when you've just
written a book-- to
moving out here, getting
his graduate degree in
Counseling Psychology
and eventually
becoming an author.
Now this sounds a lot
like our definition
in the book of what
a supersurvivor is.
Someone who encounters a trauma,
a tragedy, an illness, a loss,
some major adversity
in their life, and then
not only bounces back
but bounces forward,
often revolutionizing
their life for the better,
and often touching the world
around them in positive ways.
Now I had done,
for years, therapy
with people who were
suffering from trauma
and serious medical
illness, and my research
has all concerned how people
not only bounce back but bounce
forward in the wake of trauma.
And so this started a series
of conversations between us
that culminated in a summer
independent study project
where we worked together,
and Lee ended up
writing a stunning,
I think 20-page,
paper on some of the factors
that help people to bounce back
from trauma.
I think it's safe to say
that that 20-page paper,
and that independent
study project,
turned into one of the
most epic independent study
projects of all time and
eventually this book.
At some point, we were seated
in Nervous Dog Coffee on Mission
Street in San Francisco, and
we just looked at each other
and said there's a book here.
And the rest is not
exactly history,
but I will let Lee
catch you up from there.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ:
Sounds great.
Thanks, Dave.
As we've kind of
talked about, this
is as much about
other people as it
is our own personal journeys.
And my experience-- I
was a cancer survivor,
and when I bounced back from
it I became intensely focused
on the ways that other
people kind of bounce back.
How in the world do
people bounce back
not only after cancer but all
kinds of crazy experiences
in their lives.
Everything from natural
disasters to car accidents.
The things we have no
control over to things we do
have control over.
And then I met Dave, and Dave
is a Professor of Counseling
Psychology, but he's
also an expert in hope.
And when I met Dave, I knew that
there was a partnership here.
We had to start writing
and working together.
His research has
been the foundation
of a lot of the
studies that have
worked toward a
positive psychology.
The study of hope in general
is just fascinating stuff,
trust me.
I can't even go
there because I don't
know what I'm talking about.
But Dave does, so you
should talk to him about it.
But he said to us early on, he
said, yes there's a book here.
We need to expand it.
Beyond cancer.
But also look at all the
different types of trauma
that people experience.
And we spent months and
months defining and redefining
what a supersurvivor was.
And this was all
based on the research.
There's 20 years-- two
decades-- of research
that talks about what
we're going to talk about,
called post-traumatic growth.
We've all heard of
post-traumatic stress disorder
and the negative side of trauma,
but post-traumatic growth
is a pretty
spectacular phenomenon,
and it happens quite often,
much more than PTSD, in fact.
And we dove into the
research, and the research
was fascinating.
We saw things that
were counter-intuitive
that we'll talk about
a little bit later.
Things that just really
sparked our interest
about these clinicians, and
researchers, and writers.
And then we started matching
up case studies-- examples that
mapped perfectly
onto the science.
And that's when we
got to actually meet
our supersurvivors.
We started with
one or two and it
expanded to about 150 people.
We pared it down
to 17 for the book,
but these people were amazing.
I mean, this was one of
the best parts of our job.
We got to hang out
with people who
had survived remarkable,
remarkable things,
and then gone on to change their
lives dramatically as a result.
We met Asha Mevlana,
who we're going
to read about in a few
minutes, who went from a cancer
survivor, like me, but did
something remarkable with it.
We met a genocide
survivor who went on
to become a
presidential appointee
and ultimately actually had
an internship here at Google.
I don't know how I met her.
We met a plane
crash survivor who
went on to change the airline
industry for the better.
We met a tsunami survivor who
went on to become a rabbi.
A domestic violence survivor who
went on to become a yoga guru.
And they just kept on
getting cooler and cooler.
And there was
science behind this.
There had to be
science behind it.
And we found it, and this
is what the book's about.
Each of these stories,
and all the science,
kind of taught us ways to
live a life worth living.
I think that's the big
takeaway from our book.
We want people to
learn how to live
a life that's worth living.
You don't need a trauma
to experience that.
And that's one of our
big messages today.
This was a huge collaboration,
so thank you to Mimi,
thank you to Vin, thank
you to Dan Ariely today
for helping us out.
This is just a
spectacular moment for us.
And without further ado, we will
start to read Supersurvivors.
DAVID FELDMAN: So
we're going to read
a sort of abridged version of
Chapter One which is titled,
"To Survive or Supersurvive."
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: Thank you.
To Survive or Supersurvive.
On the spectrum of
trauma survivorship,
everyone falls somewhere
between hiding under a rock
and becoming a rock star.
Asha Mevlana lay on a table
in a small examination room
at St. Vincent Catholic Medical
Center in the West Village, New
York City, when this thought
first crossed her mind.
She was 24 years old,
dark-haired, and beautiful.
The technology industry
in 2002 was making people
all over the city rich.
She had a great job at a
startup, an apartment in Soho,
and a pearl-shaped problem
within her left breast.
Asha had already guessed
that it was cancer.
The lab technician's grim
look was merely confirmation.
The defining moment
of her ordeal however,
wasn't the diagnosis.
It also wasn't the
undeniable sensation
that her life was
spinning out of control
as she underwent eight
months of chemotherapy.
For Asha, the
defining moment came
after the doctors announced
that she was cancer-free
and sent her back
into the world.
While she'd been
facing her mortality,
everyone else had gone on
blithely living their lives.
Her co-workers talked about
the crummy New York weather,
the long lines at Starbucks, and
the finalists on American Idol.
Everyone seemed to place value
in such inconsequential things,
that she found herself
yearning for a time
when she did as well.
Life as Asha once knew it simply
didn't make sense anymore.
It seemed empty.
So she promptly
dropped out of it.
I'm not a religious
person, but I prayed.
Just give me a second
chance, and I'm
going to change my life.
I'm going to do what I'm
passionate about, she says.
DAVID FELDMAN:
Asha is not alone.
According to the
American Cancer Society,
roughly 13 million
people around the world
are diagnosed with
cancer each year,
a number that is projected to
double in the next two decades.
The journal "Neuroimaging
Clinics of North America"
provides a similarly
grim outlook,
with a startling 10 million
people worldwide affected
every year by traumatic
brain injuries.
The harsh reality
of widespread trauma
becomes even more apparent
once we combine these numbers
with the World Health
Organization's calculation
that 50 million
people a year survive
car wrecks, the UN's finding
that one out of every three
women will be beaten,
raped, or otherwise
abused during her lifetime,
and the realization
that these statistics
cover only a small portion
of the catastrophes that
befall people every day.
Harvard Medical School Professor
of Psychiatry, Judith Herman,
calls trauma the affliction
of the powerless.
The problem is
we're all powerless
against the
vicissitudes of fate.
She writes in her book,
"Trauma and Recovery,"
quote, "traumatic events are
extraordinary not because they
occur rarely, but
because they overwhelm
the ordinary human
adaptations to life," unquote.
Depending on the
particular type of trauma,
about a quarter
of survivors will
fall into post-traumatic
stress disorder,
a painful and often
debilitating condition.
Others will experience
significant depression
or anxiety.
In the midst of
all this adversity,
it's tempting to become
pessimistic and fall
into a kind of
fatalistic hopelessness.
It's easy to overlook
the amazing potential
for resilience in us
all as human beings.
Amazingly, even in
the midst of trauma,
people continue
to smile, to love,
to celebrate, to
create, to renew.
In making this
observation, we absolutely
do not mean to belittle the
impact of traumatic times,
or the suffering that many have
endured and continue to endure.
Suffering is real.
But resilience is also real.
It is an incredible
and encouraging fact
about human nature, that
contrary to popular belief,
after a period of
emotional turmoil,
most trauma survivors
eventually recover and return
to their lives.
They bounce back.
And in some cases they do more.
They bounce forward.
And sometimes in
truly remarkable ways.
They refocus their energies on
a new calling, on a new mission,
on a new path, on helping
others who have been victimized,
on education, on legal
reforms, or any number
of other big goals.
They move beyond
mere resilience.
They transform the meaning
of their personal tragedies
by making them the
basis for change.
We call these people
supersurvivors.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: In the
aftermath of her cancer
diagnosis, Asha paid for
improvisational violin lessons.
Now before surviving
the trauma, Asha
had no illusions about
making career out of music.
"You mean like
playing for bar tips?
No, it never crossed my mind.
I was just way too
practical," she remembers.
But that pragmatism didn't
survive the chemotherapy.
And after working
hard for many months,
she began playing electric
violin for a few amateur rock
bands.
Something about this
new life clicked.
Perhaps it was the
unscripted nature
that, much like
the music itself,
was creative and freeing.
A couple of months later
when a friend invited
her to visit Los
Angeles for a weekend,
she met a number
of local musicians
who convinced her she should
get paying gigs out here
in California.
It would be an enormous risk.
Asha's entire universe
was on the East Coast.
She had no job prospects in Los
Angeles, no income, no place
to live, and a million reasons
to go back to her old life.
Plus although
proficient in violin,
she was safely an amateur.
But then again she
was also 28 years old,
one of the younger survivors
of breast cancer she knew,
spiritually damaged, and
more than a little lost.
From this perspective,
she had nothing to lose.
DAVID FELDMAN: In the origin
stories of superheroes,
something profound, unexpected,
and often frightening,
transforms ordinary lives.
A massive discharge of radiation
turns a mild-mannered scientist
into a hulking green avenger.
The murder of another's parents
leads him to don a black mask
and dedicate his
life to rescuing
innocent victims of
a maniacal joker.
By the way, I just
want to point out
that we broke no
copyrights at all in that.
I bet you can't even figure
out which ones they were.
But one of these scenarios
are closer to reality
than we think.
According to nearly two
decades of research emerging
from institutions as far flung
as the University of North
Carolina Charlotte and
the University of Warwick
in England, the majority
of trauma survivors
report some degree
of positive change.
These individuals may
emerge from otherwise awful
experiences primed
with something
like x-ray vision, which
allows them to notice value
and opportunity where they might
never have seen them before.
They may develop inner
strength from having
lived through an experience
beyond their worst imaginings.
These psychological gains are
known as post-traumatic growth.
But even after experiencing
such inner growth,
most trauma survivors
find their outer lives
returning to normal.
According to
research, the majority
of post-traumatic growth
is internal and private.
It's what psychologists
refer to as perceived growth.
Survivors report that they've
changed for the better,
and they may feel the benefits
of that change, but outwardly
their lives don't
look much different
from before the trauma.
Perceived growth
isn't fake, however.
Though the research
is mixed, some studies
show links between greater
perceived growth and lower
emotional distress, as well
as better physical health.
But sometimes people
move far beyond both
the life-altering negative
effects of trauma,
and the usual outcomes
of post-traumatic growth.
These people don't just grow,
they revolutionize their lives.
They transform and
transcend their suffering
even while enduring.
These supersurvivors
radically deviate
from their previous life paths,
often transforming the worst
thing that's happened
into the best.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: So Asha
has a kick-ass Viper violin.
It's purple, and the
hourglass-shaped belly
is cleaved.
Instead of the classic
configuration of four strings,
her fingerboard is
laced with seven.
Rachmaninoff would have
been puzzled but awed.
One afternoon, Asha picked up
her violin from a repair shop
in downtown LA, and the guy who
had just made her instrument
said he knew Dee Snider, the
lead singer of Twisted Sister,
who just happened to be trying
out electric violinists to join
his new tour.
Although she knew her
chances were pretty slim,
Asha auditioned.
Two months later, she celebrated
her 30th birthday on a tour bus
with one of the top metal
vocalists of all time.
One opportunity led to the next.
With startling
swiftness, Asha was
hired to play alongside
Alanis Morissette,
and after that on a US
tour with Gnarls Barkley,
opening for the Red Hot
Chili Peppers in front
of 30,000 people a night.
That same year, she
performed at the Grammys.
Jay Z and Mary J. Blige
both tapped her to play.
Her reputation on
the rise, in 2009
she played regularly
for the American Idol
band and the Tonight Show.
Asha had been in Los
Angeles 15 months.
If someone had told
her in New York
that someday she'd be playing
in front of millions of people,
she would have
laughed in disbelief.
Yet, she'd arrived at this
place with unusual calm,
as though somewhere in
the back of her mind,
she always knew
she'd wind up here.
DAVID FELDMAN: Asha is
one of the many people
we'll meet in this book who
have dramatically altered
their lives after suffering
trauma, often discovering
hidden parts of
themselves or contributing
to the world in ways they
never thought possible.
But these people
are not superheroes.
At least no more than any
other trauma survivor.
In truth, they aren't
even superhuman.
Their stories betray
their utter humanness.
They're stumbling
and they're grasping
as they wrestle with the
fundamental questions we all
face, who am I, what
do I believe in,
and most importantly, how
should I live my life.
There is a lot
that all of us can
learn from their often
haphazard but beautiful answers
to these questions.
To be clear, this is
not a book extolling
the bright side of tragedy,
the silver lining of any cloud,
or the so-called power
of positive thinking.
No trauma is good.
Every trauma involves suffering.
There is nothing inherently
positive or indispensable
about atrocities, violence,
disasters, or illness.
But given that such events
are sometimes unavoidable,
it is important to understand
the incredible resilience it
is possible for
ordinary human beings.
The ability to peer into the
face of tragedy and somehow
emerge fundamentally
changed and able to impact
the world in previously
unimagined ways.
Drawing from research in
the fields of psychology,
psychiatry, sociology,
anthropology,
and even business, in this book
we explore why and how people
transform suffering
into personal triumph.
Each chapter focuses on a
particular principle identified
by social scientists, including
hope, personal control,
social support, forgiveness,
and spirituality.
But these principles
don't always
work the way you'd think.
We explore how hope has little
to do with positive thinking,
and how despite
conventional wisdom,
the disorientation and
groundlessness experienced
by many people after trauma
can ultimately be advantageous.
We discover why
psychologists think
that's certain delusions
can be healthy,
why forgiveness is good
for one's physiology
as well as for the soul,
and why reflecting on death
can lead to a better life.
Finally, we ask what
implications these stories
have for the rest of us,
regardless of whether we've
survived a serious
trauma or are merely
confronting the setbacks and
difficulties of everyday life.
Asha's cancer was a
transformative and meaningful
turning point.
It afforded her the
freedom and motivation
to move beyond her
previous life and build
a new reality for herself.
Instead of hampering
her, trauma freed her.
But stories like
Asha's are not typical.
While trauma leaves many
people suffering, lost,
and searching to
reclaim their lives,
Asha's experience seems to have
provided her with direction.
In this book, we discover why.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ:
And we were just
notified that apparently there
are books in the back for sale.
If anybody would like those.
DAVID FELDMAN: So
we'll take our places
and we'll welcome Dan to
the stage-- Dan Ariely--
and we'll start a conversation.
DAN ARIELY: So if
anybody has questions,
feel free to ask as well.
Let me start by asking
you, how did you
get the people you interviewed?
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: So
it started very simply.
People who had survived cancer,
people I'd met, had said to me,
hey, you know you
should meet somebody.
And we met Asha.
She was actually the very
first person that we met.
And Asha said, ah no, no, no,
no, I'm not a supersurvivor,
you should talk to my friend.
And I was like, oh OK.
So then she put me
touch with her friend.
And then Dave would meet
people the same sort of way.
And then, it took us from
individual points of contact
to major organizations.
We spoke to Desmond
Tutu at some point.
We spoke to people who have
appeared on the world stage
and made major, major
changes to the world.
That was kind of how
it started, and it just
started spiraling
after that point.
It was a wonderful experience.
DAVID FELDMAN: And
we were looking
for particular cases that
would exemplify the research.
We started by really
diving deeply,
as Lee said in his
opening, into the research
and finding out
what do the hundreds
and hundreds of studies
out there say about what
helps people to bounce forward
after trauma and experience
post-traumatic growth.
And so when we went looking,
we went looking particularly
for case studies that
would exemplify that.
So the foundation was
really the research,
and then we tried to
put flesh on the bones
and make the book
more interesting
by saying here's what this
looks like in reality.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ:
Yeah, it was fun.
DAN ARIELY: And so if you
think about supersurvivors,
how much of it is
about the individual's
inherent characteristics
versus something
that happens to them
in the environment.
So for example, Asha,
that you mentioned,
it sounded like she
had good luck, as well.
So you could imagine
a world in which
she tried to play
the violin-- and I
guess the vast majority
of violin players
have a miserable
professional career.
They end up doing
something else.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ:
I'm one of them.
DAN ARIELY: So you have
to wonder how much of it
is the individual?
How much of it is luck?
How much of it is risk taking?
If you look at
everybody here, do you
think there would be a way for
you to talk to everybody here
and identify whether they
would, in principle, be
supersurvivors?
Like is this
something about them.
DAVID FELDMAN: Boy, there's
a lot of questions in there,
let me see if I can take
them sort of one at a time.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: They're
all great questions.
DAVID FELDMAN: They're
First of all, I'm
not sure that there
is anything-- The
question we often get
is, are we talking about
immutable traits here?
There are just people who are
supersurvivors and will become
supersurvivors if
they encounter trauma,
and then people that won't.
And that's not what the
research seems to say.
Although the research seems
to say that there are certain
things, like being a
little more extroverted,
having certain kinds
of social skills,
that tend to elevate your
likelihood of growing from
trauma a little bit,
actually it's other things,
things that we all have
the opportunity to do,
things like taking
a hopeful outlook,
being a realistic thinker,
cultivating social support--
turns out that social support
and noticing and taking
advantage of social support
networks is extremely
important-- rebuilding one's
worldview in a certain way
after trauma-- I'm sort
of glossing over these--
but these are all things that
I don't think are immutable
traits-- something
about the person--
but are principles that
anyone can exemplify.
That's what the research says.
Now when we talked to
the supersurvivors, one
of the things that we noticed
was this incredible humility,
that a lot of them said,
look, don't present me
as a superhuman person.
Present me as an
ordinary person who
discovered a new way of
living through trauma.
And all of them wanted to
make sure that in the book
we got across this idea that
anyone can be a supersurvivor,
and in fact, you don't
have to wait for trauma
to wake you up to
begin to really pursue
your dreams and your goals.
DAN ARIELY: But some
of those attributes
that you described, do seem
like individual traits.
Like your ability to have a
nice social network, right?
Somebody who's an introvert
and doesn't like people
will inherently have a
harder time with this.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ:
Well it's interesting.
We actually spoke to-- anybody
here know Jane McGonigal?
Heard of her?
So Jane, when we spoke to
her about social support,
she identifies herself
as an introvert.
DAN ARIELY: She's not.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: Yeah, well
she wears pink and glitter,
but it's interesting because
she identifies, self-identifies,
as an introvert.
DAVID FELDMAN:
Let's say who she is
for those people who don't know.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: So
Jane McGonigal was a gamer.
She creates games.
And she had a
traumatic brain injury.
A very odd traumatic
brain injury.
She was cleaning her house,
and she reached up real fast
and hit her head on a drawer.
DAVID FELDMAN: She was repairing
her printer, so be careful.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: Yeah,
don't let that happen.
So she hurt her head.
And you know she had a
traumatic brain injury.
She had a concussion.
Most people recover
from concussions.
She was having a
hard time with that.
And she felt very isolated.
She stayed in her apartment.
She didn't want to leave.
The people who tried to
come in and help her,
she kind of pushed away.
She wasn't getting out.
And so what she
did was she created
a game called SuperBetter.
And with this game--
It was for anybody
who had-- it started
out with people
who just had traumatic brain
injury who were shutting
themselves in but still
wanted that connection.
So they would go online.
They would each give
each other tasks.
And if they achieve
these tasks--
And these tasks
were very simple,
like walk around the
block and then come home,
look out the window for five
minutes, give your Mom a call,
things like that.
But every time you do
that, you get points.
And she felt-- she perceived-- a
certain level of social support
that may or may not have
actually been there.
And that really helped
her tremendously.
And it's helped a lot of
people as a result as well.
DAVID FELDMAN: I think
the interesting thing
about this story, is here's
somebody who credits herself,
whether you believe it or
not, with being an introvert.
And in fact, at that point in
her life felt very withdrawn.
She found a way, a
creative way, to reach out.
And that is what we find with
a lot of the supersurvivors.
That, whether or
not they necessarily
look like supersurvivors
before, they discover
new parts of themselves, they
discover ways of reaching out,
they discover new
goals, they connect
with their values
in a way-- maybe
values that were partly sort
of covered over beforehand--
and they change in certain ways.
To answer your question.
I mean you said a lot of these
seem like personal traits.
They are.
I study hope.
And at first scientists-- I
mean hope has of course been
a philosophical and religious
topic for millennia--
but at first when
scientists started
to study this
about 50 years ago,
they treated it like hope
was a personality trait.
Either you were
a hopeful person,
or you were a less hopeful--
a hopeless-- person.
And it turns out,
that my own research,
that I've done during
the past 10 years or so,
has shown that hope, this
thing that people thought
was a trait, is
actually very malleable.
That if you put people
through a 90 minute workshop
to teach hopeful
thinking skills,
that they can dramatically
change the way that they think.
And you see effects from
that three to six months
down the road in
terms of their mood,
in terms of their ability
to accomplish goals,
in terms of-- if you do it on
college students-- in terms
of their GPA rising.
So I think a lot of
these things that
seem to be immutable traits
are actually very mutable.
DAN ARIELY: Just as a
question for the audience.
How many of you think that if
something terrible happened
to you, that you would change
your life in positive ways.
How many of you think that
you would be supersurvivors?
DAVID FELDMAN: Or something
like a supersurvivor?
DAN ARIELY: How many don't know?
And how many think
that you would
be just a plain old survivor?
Do people have a sense
of what they will be?
So people here have some
kind of thing intuition
of whether they would
be better off or not.
DAVID FELDMAN: That's
a really good question.
DAN ARIELY: And is it
possible that the people who
think that they--
those of you who
think you'll be a supersurvivor,
that you just take more risk
and therefore have a higher
chance to experience a trauma?
DAVID FELDMAN: Let me
take a stab at that
and then I'll turn
it over to Lee
because I know he wants
to talk about risk.
If I know you well enough.
I don't know the answer
to that question,
and I think we just need
to put it out there.
I don't think anybody knows
the answer to that question.
That's a fascinating
research question, and one
that I'd love to
do actual work on.
Can people who end
up supersurvivors,
can they prospectively predict
whether they will or not.
People do have an ability
to assess, to self-assess,
their own level of
some of the traits,
or characteristics,
or principles
that we're talking about.
I mean you all can ask yourself
right now, how good am I
at achieving my goals?
How honest am I with myself
when something bad happens?
Or do I tend to practice denial?
Do I tend to paint a
smiley face over things
rather than accept them?
How good are you at acceptance?
How quickly do you snap back
from problems, daily problems,
when they occur in your lives?
How well do you cultivate
your social support network?
How good are you at reaching
out and asking for help
when you really need it?
Or are you the
kind of person who
doesn't like to ask for help?
I think you can self-assess
some of these characteristics,
and to the extent that those
self-assessments are accurate,
and generally
people's are, I think
you could predict for yourself.
But whether just asking
it is a prediction,
it's an interesting question.
DAN ARIELY: Is there
like a little trauma,
we can just try out and see--
DAVID FELDMAN: So what
do we do to you today?
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ:
Yes seriously,
who wants a traumatic
brain injury,
I can help you with that.
DAVID FELDMAN: Right, yeah,
we've got a bat somewhere.
So the research shows that 50 to
80% of people-- a lot of people
don't believe this statistic
when we say it, but it's true.
In worldwide surveys,
epidemiological surveys,
with 10s of thousands
of participants,
we know that 50 to 80% of
people during their lifetime,
at some point, will
suffer a trauma.
50 to 80%.
And we're not talking
about little traumas,
we're talking about
the big things--
natural disasters,
major victimizations,
physical traumas,
assaults, et cetera.
And only about 20 to 25%, as
we said, end up with PTSD.
The majority bounce back.
So I think the majority
of us-- and that's
not to say that
PTSD is unimportant,
it's extremely important as
a topic, and people with PTSD
deserve treatment and
the topic deserves
a lot of conversation--
but 50 to 80%
of people in the
aftermath of trauma, grow.
So I think it's
actually something
that we all have built in
to us to a certain degree.
DAN ARIELY: Don't develop PTSD
is not the same as growing?
Absolutely.
And these are not
mutually exclusive either.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ:
Right, that's
the other thing, they're
not mutually exclusive.
DAVID FELDMAN: Sometimes,
it's in fact, well
you can speak to this.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: Oh sure.
Sure.
I mean we interviewed-- One
of the subjects in our book
survived genocide.
And she did remarkable
stuff afterwards.
She really bounced forward.
She worked with Oprah Winfrey
at the Leadership Academy
for Girls, as a
presidential appointee
to the United States
Holocaust Memorial
Museum with her hero,
Elie Wiesel, on and on.
But when you talk to
her, she still tears up.
She still is quite fearful.
She displays a lot of the
negative effects of trauma.
And that really points out
that these things are not
mutually exclusive, that
many times, often times,
the negative effects
and the positive effects
happen at the same time.
And to the point
though about-- We
talk in the book a
little bit about delusion
and taking chances.
So one of the
things we found was
that most of the
people in the book
had something that we
called, grounded hope.
And so grounded
hope-- It's two parts.
The first part is you look
at the situation you're
in with eyes wide open.
Don't paint a
smiley face over it.
This is the circumstance
that I face.
There's no getting around the
fact that I've lost my vision.
fact that I've lost a limb,
or that I have
experienced this trauma.
That's the grounded part.
The hopeful part is looking at
the things that you can change.
And we found somebody--
There's a man in our book,
his name is Casey-- it's
actually his birthday today,
so if you're watching
Happy Birthday--
but he survived a car accident
where he lost one of his legs.
And today he's one
of Hollywood's most
sought after stuntmen.
He's been blown up 50, 60 times.
DAVID FELDMAN: His specialty
is getting his leg blown off.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: It is.
It's really great.
DAVID FELDMAN: Which
makes a lot of sense.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ:
It's wonderful.
You have aliens ripping it off.
You have police officers
shooting his leg off.
It's actually really
harrowing stuff.
When we asked him
what it was, he
said he feels like-- he
thought he could do this.
He had this delusional idea,
this slightly delusional idea,
that he could do this
and be safe at it.
And many people who
become supersurvivors
have this idea, this
sense of confidence,
that they can try
many different things.
And one or two of
them will work out.
Many of them don't.
And that's the important
thing to note too.
Failure is part of
this whole equation.
Goal disengagement is
part of this equation.
But goal re-engagement is
also part of the equation,
and people try new things.
DAVID FELDMAN: Let me fill
in a little more there.
One of the things that Casey
said, which is amazing,
is he said, look I feel
like-- and this is something
we saw in a lot of
our interviews--
I feel like I've lived through
the worst thing I can possibly
imagine.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ:
That's right.
DAVID FELDMAN: He
was pushing a car
by the side of the
road, that had broken
down-- he was 19 years old--
and a drunk driver careened
into the rear bumper,
ripping one of his legs off.
He said, I feel like I've
lived through the worst
possible thing
that I can imagine.
Nothing else is scary.
And now I am willing
to open myself
up to trying a lot of new things
and taking some risks because I
know I can survive it.
And that willingness
to take risks,
I think what some people would
call that slightly delusional
sense that I can
handle anything,
actually is what has enabled
him to be incredibly successful.
DAN ARIELY: So
this sounds like it
fits with the research on luck,
that basically says that there
are lucky people and there
are non-lucky people,
and lucky people are
not better at roulette,
they just try more things.
DAVID FELDMAN: Right.
Exactly.
DAN ARIELY: They try
at least a little bit,
and something seems
to be going well,
and then they keep on doing.
And some people just
don't try as much.
But it opens another
question, which
is, what is the
cause of the trauma?
So if you think about a
trauma like a car accident,
it's a one-time trauma.
It's caused by a one-time event.
And then on the hand,
there are things
like learned helplessness.
Right?
There are experiences
of somebody
who's being abused
for a long time.
The environment
is unpredictable.
They don't have control
over it, and so on.
Do you find differences
between the type
of-- If it's about the
willingness to take risk,
is learned helplessness going
to lead to less willingness
to take risk.
And one-time events are just
going to give us more courage,
then what else can happen?
DAVID FELDMAN: So
there's a lot there too.
So let me see if I can
take the first part.
There are certainly
different kinds of trauma.
And the type of trauma
makes a big difference
as to what the outcome will be.
So for instance, we know that
for one-time traumas that
are non-personal, so they're not
perpetrated by an individual,
it's a freak event-- a
fire or an earthquake--
those are a lot less traumatic.
People have a lower degree of
post-traumatic stress disorder.
And they have a
higher level-- they
tend to grow more as a result
of those sorts of events.
Things that are
personal traumas--
so we're talking
about rape here,
we're talking about
personal abuse
by someone else-- these
are more traumatic.
They tend to lead to
higher rates-- combat
is another one-- they tend to
lead to higher rates of PTSD.
The rate of PTSD in combat
is between 30 and 40%,
whereas the mean of all the
rates is more like 20 to 30%.
And those tend to lead
more to learn helplessness,
particularly if
they are repeated.
So when we talk about the
certain percentage of people
who end up with PTSD,
these are all the factors
that go into it.
And when a person
ends up with PTSD,
the good news is we have very
good treatments for that.
This is for the vast
majority of people
not at all a chronic
condition if you
get appropriate
psychological treatment.
The medicines don't work
as well as the therapies.
Therapies like cognitive
behavior therapy,
exposure therapy, cognitive
processing therapy,
tend to work in the
neighborhood of 70% of the time
to help people to
overcome what you're
calling the learned
helplessness,
or learned hopelessness,
that goes along
with this, along with the
nightmares, and the flashbacks,
and the reliving,
and things like that.
The interesting thing
is that very often,
in the process of
these therapies-- now
this is documented by
research-- in the process
of these therapies, people grow.
And often not measured,
but when you do measure it
you see it, an outcome of
therapy for Post-Traumatic
Stress Disorder, is
post-traumatic growth.
DAN ARIELY: So it's not
just the individual,
it's the environment and
the kind of injury as well.
And we think that luck also
has something to do with it.
You mentioned that this is
not about recommending people
to start jumping
in front of cars.
That trauma is terrible,
and awful, and so on.
To what extent do the
people that you talked to,
have a sense that
there was something
in this experiences
that was worth it.
It's terrible to say
I would do it again,
but they see it as an overall
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ:
There's some positive?
DAN ARIELY: Not some positive.
Some positive I can see.
But they see it overall as
more positive than negative?
DAVID FELDMAN: Well I
can answer that question
from the research,
but why don't you
answer that question from the
actual 17 supersurvivors first.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: Well I
can talk about that even just
from my own personal experience.
When I was going
through treatment,
somebody sent me a "New
York Times" article--
it was an Op Ed-- that said I
am so glad that I got cancer.
It changed my life, and
now I'm doing things
that I never thought I would do.
Personally, that just
really bothered me.
I thought it was the
worst thing on earth.
And I would give a million
dollars, I'd give $2 million.
I'd give everything
I'd ever earn
to never have that experience.
Because it was-- as much as I
grew from it-- it was painful,
it was hard.
And I still think about that
and think about, God, I never
ever want to go through that.
And I hope people I love and
know, don't go through that.
So I think, from a
personal experience,
I don't relate to that.
And I think, it depends on the
supersurvivors you talk to.
Some of them thought that,
yeah, it actually turned out
to be a pretty darn
good thing, and they
wouldn't change anything.
Because that's the way life
was supposed to happen,
and that's what they do with it.
And what they did with
it was the only thing
that they could do with it.
Other people-- We met a
guy who was a businessman.
He made millions and
millions of dollars--
this is a pretty quick
story-- he made millions
of dollars selling jambalaya.
That's what he did.
He sold jambalaya.
He went to business school.
DAVID FELDMAN: He was the CEO of
a company that made jambalaya.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: Right.
I mean he made a lot
of money very fast.
At 9/11, as everybody
did-- they all
felt the effects, the
vicarious traumatic effects,
even if you didn't know anybody
who died in the attacks.
His best friend was the
co-pilot that hit the Pentagon.
And he asked himself,
OK, well, life is short,
and I want to make the
biggest impact I possibly can
on the world, what can I do.
He liquidated his assets, sold
this company to his investors
for a song, and moved into a
parish and became a priest.
And now he lives of
$70 a month, and he
was one of the first people back
after Katrina hit New Orleans
and help rebuild that community.
It was a remarkable story.
I asked him, would
you give all this up
to have your friend back.
And he said, without a doubt.
Without a doubt.
DAVID FELDMAN: And I think
the research coincides
with what Lee is saying.
If you ask people
who-- that 50 to 80%
of people who-- grow in some
way as a result of trauma,
was it worth it?
Was this growth like
a really good thing?
And people would
always say no, I'd
trade in this growth to not
have suffered the trauma.
DAN ARIELY: So there are
people like Dan Gilbert, who
wrote "Stumbling on
Happiness" and a lot of papers
on this question, and it
includes both a question
of adaptation and
growth-- And he
has the opposite perspective.
So when I talk to him
about my own experience.
and I think it's--
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: You are very
much a supersurvivor I think.
DAN ARIELY: I don't.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ:
That's another sign
that you are a supersurvivor.
I'm not one but you are.
DAN ARIELY: But he
thinks I'm wrong.
When I say that I don't
think it was worth it,
he thinks I'm wrong because
of the research on adaptation
and an inability to do this.
Actually, I have
one more question.
I have the kind of injury
where I have lots of scars.
And I've wondered
whether having scars
is actually a good reminder of
the differences between being
injured and not being injured.
So if you think about somebody
who-- I think like you.
You look in the mirror,
other people see you,
they don't see anything, and
you don't see to yourself.
You just have to think
about it or remember it.
There are some
injuries that you just
have the constant
reminder of that.
And I can think about
why that would be good
and why it could be bad.
It's a reminder of how
life would look like.
At the same time,
it's a reminder
I'm alive, nevertheless,
after some challenges.
DAVID FELDMAN: It's
a good question.
I don't know--
Perhaps, you do know
of research that supports this.
I can tell you
that when we talked
to some of the
supersurvivors, particularly
for the chapter
on social support,
one of the things
that they said to us
was-- Because we talked
to two people who
had brain injuries
for that chapter.
And the thing that's common to
a person who has a brain injury,
is that they look perfectly
normal, even though they
may have trouble finding words,
doing math, thinking straight,
planning.
They may have immense
emotional difficulties.
Lee mentioned Jane McGonigal,
who was very depressed
and even at one
point was suicidal
and felt very isolated.
And yet her friends
treated her very normal.
So she felt very
alone and isolated.
And we did hear people say, I
wish that I had something that
would make me look
more traumatized,
so that I wouldn't have to
constantly be explaining it,
so that people would care
for me in a different way.
I don't know what the numbers
are behind that sort of thing,
but I do think
that that happens.
I've seen that clinically too.
DAN ARIELY: So the
argument is that there
could be an element
of the person thinking
about their own life,
but there could be also
the environmental factor,
where other people just
stop thinking of you as
being sick, or injured,
or needing help.
DAVID FELDMAN: Yes.
And often will
withdraw their support
because they look at you and
you look perfectly normal.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: You're fine.
What do you need my help for.
DAVID FELDMAN: What do
you need my help for?
DAN ARIELY: So you mentioned
a few times, social support.
It seems to be very important.
It's important for lots
of good functioning.
If you were giving a
recommendation for somebody
who's recently injured, in terms
of how to improve their social
networking, outside of switching
from Facebook to Google+.
DAVID FELDMAN: Of course, that
would be the recommendation.
I mean that's number one.
[LAUGHTER]
I can take this, and
it's a counter-intuitive
recommendation.
So the research, and
certainly our experience
with the supersurvivors
and my clinical experience,
shows very clearly that
one of the number one
protective factors against
the effects of trauma,
one of the number
one things that
allows people to bounce back
and even forward after trauma,
is social support.
But there is a twist here,
and it's a big twist.
And that is that it's possible
to be surrounded by people who
love you and care for you and
want to support you and not
realize it.
That this is one of
those areas in psychology
where perception and reality are
actually two different things
and can be separated.
Trauma is incredibly
alienating, and people
in the aftermath of
trauma often withdraw.
The majority of people
withdraw to a certain degree.
A lot of people believe
no one could possibly
understand what
they're going through.
So they could literally be
surrounded, we could literally
be surrounded, by
a sea or virtually
be surrounded by a
sea of social support,
and think we're in a desert.
And so the advice
that I would give is,
notice the support
that is there for you.
It turns out, it doesn't
take a lot of support.
It just takes you noticing
it, being open to it,
and accessing it.
That perception that
people are there for you,
turns out to be far more
psychologically important
than having some
huge support network.
So notice it.
DAN ARIELY: I guess that's
really good news for Google+.
DAVID FELDMAN: And
there's lots of research
that shows that these
sorts of networks
are effective in helping
people bounce forward.
DAN ARIELY: Great.
Any-- yes.
AUDIENCE: One of the
things that seems
to be a recurring theme
in a lot of these stories,
is that people realize
that they don't
have to follow the rules
that they were set out
to have before, and maybe
they have different values.
And I can imagine a lot of
other life circumstances
that have that effect, like
kids go away to college,
or you get out of prison,
or lots of things that this.
How similar is it
to other things
that might cause you to
abandon the rules and value
something different.
DAN ARIELY: So you're
asking, can you
get the benefits
without the costs?
Can you get like
the life-growth,
minimizing bodily harm.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: Thank
God the answer is yes.
I mean, my God,
wouldn't it just be
horrible if you were just living
in this matrix-like stupor
your whole life, and it
took like getting punched
in the face, with the trauma,
to have this moment of, wake up!
No.
Thank God.
The people we spoke to in this
book, the supersurvivors here,
it took trauma to do it.
And many of them told us that
it doesn't have to be trauma.
It just happened to
be trauma for them.
So like you said,
getting out of prison,
having your kids
go off to college,
something needs to
shake you out of this.
And in many cases-- the people
in our book, the supersurvivors
we spoke to-- it
was facing death.
I mean, that had the
most profound effect
on most of these people.
DAVID FELDMAN: And
by the way there's
lots of research that
shows people can face death
without actually facing death.
So there was this
researcher, whose last name
is Cozzolino, I think
its Philip Cozzolino,
who did a number of studies
a number of years ago.
And where he had
research participants,
college students mostly, who
don't think a lot about death,
come into a lab.
And he simply had
them reflect on
how they might die, what
would happen to their body
after they died,
and then reflect,
like I did in my class, what
has your life exemplified up
until now, and what would
you like it to mean.
And it turns out that
if you have people
do that, they get less greedy,
they become more spiritual,
they become more invested in
their own personal intrinsic
goals, they start to break
some of the rules of achieving
extrinsic goals that
society wants for them.
We talk a lot about that
sort of thing in our book,
and say we can learn
from these stories.
We don't have to have
gone through this.
AUDIENCE: I think maybe
like on a social level,
I think maybe on a Google
scale or something like that,
how do you make a society
where people are encouraged
to find their own rules
kind of situation.
DAVID FELDMAN: That is
too big of a question
to answer in one minute.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ: But it's
a great cause to look into.
I would love for
there to be something
like that, that would
just get them there.
DAN ARIELY: It sound to me
like a Disneyland ride that
gets you to be a
supersurvivor at the end.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ:
What a great idea.
DAN ARIELY: You
get to face death.
You get to reflect on life.
DAVID FELDMAN: I do
think to the extent
that we can put a sense of
control over people's lives
into their hands-- I think,
for instance, that YouTube
is a wonderful example of
how you're putting tools
into somebody's
hands to have control
to be able to achieve goals.
I think to the extent
that we can say,
here are the controls,
do something with them.
Those are ingredients--
At least in my research,
to the degree that
people believe
they're behind the levers
of control and creation,
they tend to feel
more hopeful, and they
tend to behave in
more intrinsic ways.
That's a quick answer but
it's a complex question.
DAN ARIELY: And like all good
things-- Thank you very much.
And I just want to say,
on a personal note,
about twice a week I get
an email from somebody
who was just injured.
And they ask me questions
about-- They really
want to ask questions
about their own lives.
Last week I got an
email from an aunt
of a young girl whose jealous
boyfriend spilled acid
on her face.
So I get lots of these
emails from people
who are really struggling.
These are people who
just got the injured.
They're in the first step.
I think it's unclear what
kind of path they will take.
And they ask me for some
feedback, some advice,
some insight into how
life would look like.
And lots of time I give
them practical things
in terms of how you find
passion, and interest, and so
on.
But I think your work kind of
gives another dimension to it
in terms of what are the
elements that you need
to explore, and how do you
get back a feeling of control.
And I think the social elements
are incredibly important.
So I thank you very much.
And this was a great book,
and topic, and very important.
I appreciate it.
LEE DANIEL KRAVETZ:
Thank you very much.
DAVID FELDMAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]